beginning today the United States of
America gets back control of its borders
we are going to get the bad ones out the
criminals and the drug deals and gangs
and gang members and cartel leaders the
day is over when they can stay in our
country and wreak havoc
president Trump announcing executive
orders today to begin building a wall
along our entire border with Mexico and
to cut federal funding for sanctuary
cities time to bring in our panel
shutter Goldburg from the National
Review Eli's Stoker's White House
correspondent for Politico and Charles
hurt from The Washington Times well Eli
how much of this can the president do by
executive order doesn't he need Congress
to approve it Lee some of this wall
project which is going to cost more than
ten billion dollars and doesn't he need
some congressional approval to cut off
all funding for sanctuary cities yeah
astronaut special about this today how
you gonna do this with existing funding
and they said well this is just sort of
a beginning point I mean it's important
for the president to show that he's
following through on these campaign
promises and there's a sort of symbolic
aspect to a lot of this now it's
consequential obviously that he's asking
to do all this but you're not going to
add 5,000 ice agents and build a wall
along the entire southern border just
using existing funds we have a sense of
how much existing funds we're talking
about that they have already in no I
mean they're gonna try to collect more
fines they think there's some savings
they can find but but nowhere close to
billions of dollars that it will take
just to build a wall never mind hiring
more people building more detention
centers a lot of things they're sort of
throwing out there today and and this is
sort of just you know not really talking
about the how to pay for it where the
details will be in terms of how you
force sanctuary cities how you get the
grants away from them but this is the
starting point symbolically it does send
a message well given and we're going to
get to the Democrat pushback today is
not going to be a real problem
particularly when you get to the Senate
and the filibuster yeah they will need
60 votes somewhere so but you know Paul
Ryan said he's open to some funding for
a potential border wall appropriating
more money for DHS and m4 for building
this out so it's possible but they are
going to have to work with some
Democrats at some point because this is
going to be subject to the filibuster
the end of it the president is talking
about signing more executive orders this
week limiting the number of refugees and
even people just coming in on visas from
countries that have a recent history of
terrorism is this in a sense kind of a
cleaned up version of the Muslim ban
that he advanced in the campaign oh I
think so I mean sure it's a way to do it
in a more responsible way which is to
say you know separately they say you're
gonna ban Muslims is I would argue
unconstitutional but more importantly
unworkable what are gonna do make ticket
agents at every Airport become experts
in Sharia and start quiz people I mean
it just makes no sense but I do think
you know more broadly Donald Trump was
given a gift by the Obama administration
by because Obama worked his pen and
phone so assiduously he created an
enormous amount of flexibility for
Donald Trump to do much the same thing
the interesting thing are sort of
ridiculous thing that we're hearing a
lot today is that somehow conservatives
or Republicans are hypocritical for
supporting Trump doing these executive
orders when we criticized Barack Obama
for doing the same thing but all of
these executive orders so far are pretty
much within the normal authority of the
President of the United States
he hasn't legislated he hasn't done
anything that were the substance of the
criticisms against Obama no one was
against executive orders as executive
orders they're against using them as a
substitute for going to Congress and I
think he will go to Congress and my
guess is well I think it's you're
absolutely right there's gonna be a
tough fight this is a great political
fight for Donald Trump to have to go to
Congress and say well the Democrats
don't want to secure the border that
that's a fight that's good we the
Republicans are the other side of
protecting the country and enforcing the
borders and Democrats won't let's talk
about that though Charlie because mr.
Trump's actions this week to crack down
on immigration both legal and illegal
have already provoked a sharp backlash
on Capitol Hill let's look first at what
the president said in an interview today
with ABC News and then congressional
Democratic reaction so the American
taxpayer will pay for the wall at first
all it is is will be reimbursed at a
later date from whatever transaction we
make from Mexico the American people are
going to be stuck with a 25 billion
bill to build a wall that most likely is
going to be ineffective so Charlie would
what how is this gonna play out on
Capitol Hill well I think it's terrific
the Democrats are now worried about
overspending here in Washington that's a
nice turn but the truth of the matter is
while Donald Trump's tone on all of this
and his his emphases 'im on enforcing
all of these laws is a dramatic
departure I think from previous
presidents of either party the vast vast
majority I would say actually probably
everything that he mentioned today is
already at least in some form in some
broad brush form in part of the the
Canon of federal law the idea of
building a fence along the along the
southern border is already part of the
law the idea that we're supposed to
deport illegals that are in this country
it's already part of the law now there
are some things that obviously are going
to drive people crazy you know the open
borders crowd crazy such as this one of
the things that he included in this was
that instead of taking of illegals that
are caught at the border or wherever and
returning them to the country of origin
he says no now we can and this is part
of law we could we can return them
wherever they came from so that means if
they're from Honduras you can send them
back to Mexico because they came through
Mexico and that's that that's a very hot
button issue but probably something that
you know that is going to be you know
that will stop you know put up the
bright neon sign that Barack Obama had
up that said you know vacancy you know
welcome you know we'll turn that to
don't come Eli another part of this of
course is the second part of candidate
Trump's pledge which was we're going to
build a wall is and we're going to make
Mexico pay for it and apparently the
backlash now that this is really on the
docket it is taught that the Mexican
president might cancel his visit here
right this isn't just about immigration
it will bleed into other agenda items
trade the president wants to renegotiate
NAFTA and have a relationship working
relationship with Mexico when you
politicize this to this degree you know
Mexico sees his tweets people in Mexico
hear what's going on in Washington right
now
and this does not improve relationships
you know back and forth across the
border that will affect other issues I
think what's interesting and and Charlie
got at this a little bit but President
Trump by winning did change the politics
of immigration for a long time a lot of
Republicans and Democrats shared the
view that you couldn't win with this
platform that Hispanic voters would
would run the other way and that you
couldn't be this extreme on immigration
and and when Trump has changed that and
he has did at that in part by you know
expressing empathy for the victims of
crimes committed by undocumented
immigrants who were here part of this
executive order is for the DHS to
publicize monthly the crimes committed
by undocumented immigrants in this
country and I think what Democrats and
everybody has to give Trump his do on is
his masterful messaging on this and a
number of other issues whether you see
through some of it whether some of it's
based on you know flimsy facts or
whatever you have to give him some
credit for drawing attention to things
and sort of flipping this around he gets
asked questions about you know what
about what will you say to Hispanic
families who are worried about their
parents being deported and Sean Spicer
says well he has a lot of empathy for
that he's a family man but what he
prefer to talk about is empathy for
victims of these crimes the government
is now directed to publicize information
about that they were very aware of the
need to sort of push their Nair all
right